welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your captain paul
aka the guy version of a plane jane and
it's time to turn off your airplane mode
because we're going full spoilers ahead
on the flight attendant
the hbo max show has just dropped its
season one finale
and throughout this video we're gonna be
breaking it all down there will be heavy
spoilers here
so if you haven't finished the show yet
then i highly recommend that you take
off
if you don't want anything ruined make
sure you smash that thumbs up button if
you think we've got a good
altitude and don't forget to subscribe
to the channel for
breakdowns like this every day terrible
anyway without the way thank you for
clicking this
now let's get into the flight attendant
okay so season one follows cassie a
flight attendant who has a one night
stand with a first-class passenger from
one of her flights
the next day she wakes up with little
memory of what happened the night before
and to her surprise finds him dead in
the bed beside her
it's enough to give you a receding
airline and rather than hanging around
at the crime scene
she ends up bowing boeing gun
all she knows is that he was sat in c3c
i wish someone would kill three c films
because he's taking all me bloody views
anyway i'll stop with the puns now
and the season follows her as she tries
to unearth the mystery behind who did it
whilst she's pursued by not only the fbi
but also a mysterious woman named
miranda
now miranda was actually going to be
played by sonia mizuno
but the show recast her role with
michelle gomez due to the creative team
wanting more of a villain type i do
think that gomez works
really well and fans of chilling
adventures of sabrina will
instantly recognize her as one of the
great bad guys in that show
now cassie is also an alcoholic and
because of her poor grip on reality
she slips into what may or may not be a
fantasy
in which she talks to alex the man from
3c
to me alex represents her subconscious
and he appears as someone like her
father
who lost their life at a young age due
to their actions and this specter makes
her confront her issues
alex at one point says he's not the man
she met in that hotel room
and thus we can't take it there's no
real supernatural element to what's
going on
the showrunner referred to this as
cassie's mind place and it's more
somewhere that we can hear her in a
dialogue without just hearing cassie's
voice
whilst her lips are closed now cassie
can often be found here denying that
she's an alcoholic
and at several points we discover that
she lies to herself and remembers things
incorrectly in order to shield herself
from the truth
we discover that cassie's father died
during a drink driving accident whilst
she was also in the car
and that she feels responsible for this
because the pair were drinking buddies
upon exiting the vehicle a small rabbit
ran up to her
and this like alex has been a ghost
that's haunted her for some time
rabbits are actually laced throughout
the show and even the cool intro
graphics contain them chasing after what
appears to be cass
this kind of hints at the show's true
meaning is about childhood trauma
and how it can lead to addiction and
that this can cause problems that
continue throughout someone's life
this leads the good time girl getting
herself into a lot of trouble
and it quickly becomes apparent that
there are bigger things going on than
she's truly able to comprehend
now the show is very frantically edited
and though i don't think that it's
necessarily for everyone
it must be doing something right as it's
currently the most popular hbo max show
it's already been greenlit for a second
season and there are a lot of things to
talk about
in regards to that too i'll discuss it
all later but the flight attendant is
very hitchcocky and in its core mystery
and every episode seems to unearth
something about the key characters in it
that paint them out in a new light
now nowhere is this scene more than in
miranda and
initially she seems like an antagonist
but we actually learned that she was one
of alex's allies and that he was killed
because he discovered his family were
involved with some criminal clients
alex took over 200 million dollars of
their money and moved it in order to try
and undo all the wrong his family had
done
with one good deed miranda attempted to
talk him out of it
which unfortunately fell on deaf ears
now we discover that the character was
killed because of a client named victor
who was using his assassin felix to tidy
up all the loose ends
this was actually unearthed in episode 7
titled hitchcock double
which in cinema terms means that
characters have doubles and
doppelgangers
this was seen in his films like psycho
vertigo and so on
but here it's been used to show that
though initially miranda and cassie were
opposites
they're actually on the same side we
discover that alex hid the codes to the
accounts in his copy of crime and
punishment
and just the name of this novel of
course shows the mind state that he had
when carrying out the deed
now the plot of this book involves a man
committing a crime in order to get money
which he promises to use to pay back to
society once he gets higher up the
social chain
it really asks the question whether
doing something bad can actually have a
positive outcome
and it's clearly something that alex
wrestled with he likely thought that
stealing the money would mean he could
make a positive change
after his family benefited from being
criminals and though
we never got a chance to see the outcome
he sort of becomes an inspiration for
what's to come
after killing the character felix was
unable to find the work because cassie
took the buck with her when she left the
room
and thus we learned he'd been stalking
her to discover where the money was
miranda realizes that they're living on
borrowed time and tries to get cassie to
run away with her
and this means that they'll be
constantly looking over their shoulder
however they will still be alive cassie
agrees and they go to an alcoholics
anonymous meeting
which is somewhat of a cathartic
experience for the character
as she's still in denial about her
drinking problem this meeting causes her
to have a panic attack as she recalls
her father's death
and later we discover that the entire
time she's blamed herself for his
passing
because she sees herself as someone that
enabled his drinking
as an audience though we know that isn't
the case and it's actually her father
who was looking for someone to use as a
crush
so that he could continue with his
addiction this is why he hated his son
and cassie's brother so much because he
was the one person who wouldn't get
involved with his activity
because cassie ran away after her father
died it's caused a sort of reflex and
pattern of behavior in her that means
every time something gets difficult her
first instinct is to run
now whilst this works in the short term
a lifetime of doing this means that
person becomes ill-equipped with dealing
with actual problems
and cassie realizes she always runs when
things get tough
because she's faced the truth of the
matter head-on she decides to break the
habit of a lifetime
and with miranda they come up with a new
plan
this involves using her as bait and
together they'll travel to rome
and finally put an end to it all miranda
wants to make one last pit stop
and goes to kill victor however she's
injured and thus misses the flight
miranda does eventually go to help her
and this is a real defining moment for
the character
in which he stops being so selfish and
actually wants to do a good deed for
someone else
likely inspired by alex and cassie left
on her own in a foreign country
cassie goes to a barman named enrico
that she met earlier in the season
this actually leads to a defining moment
after speaking with his grandmother she
confronts her past once and for all
and dumps all of the bottles of vodka
that she'd taken vowing not to drink
again
cassie and enrico go to a hotel room
which is when things really hit the fan
and felix attempts to kill them both
however a big twist comes when it's
revealed that cassie's co-worker shane
is actually a cia agent and he comes in
in an almost deus ex machina form
to shoot felix and save the day he
survives which could mean that he's
gonna be around for season two
but finally being set free means that
cassie can right the wrongs of the past
and she repairs her relationship with
her brother now turns out that shane was
actually brought on board to monitor
megan
who was accidentally given federal
secrets to the korean government
and therefore she's committed treason
megan thought that she was just giving
information about her husband's company
to a rival one
but it actually goes far beyond that for
quite some time she's been carrying out
illegal activities
and this escalated to the point that
things got beyond her control
and she's now wanted by the us in an
interview with variety
showrunner steve jockey talked about her
arc and said the following
we always pitched megan as the star of
our own little movie that's running
inside her head
this is of course reflected in the
speech in which he says she saw herself
as a sort of spy
and jockey continued by stating in a
traditional thriller you're like
when is this megan's story going to
cross with the a story
when are we going to find out that megan
is actually part of the weapon smuggling
or that she works for lionfish but our
choice in the writer's room because we
were playing fast and loose with these
thriller tropes was
what if his story never crosses with the
plot what if instead
it crosses it in an emotional way so
that's why we ended up with the two of
them
sitting with each other in the finale
and really out of that conversation they
realized all of the ways that they are
the same
and they realized they have to fix this
for themselves megan
really cements the decision that she's
going to run away and figure out how to
make this better
he'll leave that conversation changed
but from the beginning cassie didn't
want to be involved in this at all
and was stumbling through it whilst
megan on the other hand
really went into this with her eyes
opened and thought she could handle it
on her own
thus megan's issues in which things all
went out of control
also reflect cassie's addiction and it's
clear that the pair realized they share
some common ground
megan goes on the run but she leaves
behind the flash drive in order to save
her husband
from the crime that she committed megan
says goodbye to her son
and then flees likely living the life
that cassie would have had had she not
confronted her problems
in the end we discover that cassie has
started to attend alcoholics anonymous
meetings
and that she's received her first chip
which shows she's willing to work at it
you see her almost take a drink on board
a flight but she puts it back
and it's also at this point that things
start looking brighter for her
she could have spiraled into getting
drunk once more but this putting it to
the side opens up new opportunities
and shane returns to his post and says
the cia want her to work as a human
asset on their team
cassie goes back to the hotel room in
her mind and we see that alex is no
longer there
this shows that she is finally free of
the sight of her that was making her
confront her own trauma
and that she's finally managed to get
over it the lights go out and she
returns to the bed
to find alex's crime and punishment book
which he picks up
now that ends the season but if we flash
back to earlier in the episode
we saw that this was actually placed
into a code by miranda
and therefore something has to be going
on here
we learned that miranda had taken the
bank information out but she left it out
saying that she will see her
soon opposite the page we can also see
the line discussing how one tiny bad
deed
can be wiped out by a thousand good ones
which shows that
she has turned a page that okay that was
a pretty bad pun
i have seen some people taking this as
miranda going off and living the high
life
however i think that she will have been
inspired by alex
i will instead use this money to help
other people
we saw on the plane that she questioned
why she was going to help cassie
even though she tied up all the loose
ends her side so i think this hints out
what will be happening with her down the
line
when discussing things with collider
yoki said that cassie picking this up at
the end
symbolizes how much the work reflected
the journey she's been on
and that this could be why we see her
smirking in the closing scene
as for season two it was officially
greenlit on the 18th of december
and judging by the previous production
schedule we can expect the follow-up to
air early 2022
season one started filming in november
of last year but as things haven't begun
production yet
i would say that's the safest bet now
though we know little about the plot
details
i think that the second season will take
a big focus on megan
and with most of cassie's issues
resolved it makes sense to focus on
someone who still has a lot of problems
megan was of course a flight attendant
too so they wouldn't even have to change
the title
in order to make it work i doubt that
cassie will be cast to the side though
and miranda will probably come back to
reveal what she has in store for the
character
you also know that felix is alive and
judging by how skilled he was
uh i can't see him being chained up for
too long now either way it's gonna be
great to see the characters back
i'll of course keep you up to date with
what's going on as we get more
announcements
don't forget that on the 30th of
december we're giving away three copies
of the lord of the rings 4k box set to
our subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of the
mandalorian finale
which will be linked on screen right now
we go over the entire thing from top to
bottom
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more without the way
thank you for sitting through the video
we had a spot of bother back there but
we're through the worst of it now
so sit back put your feet up and relax
as we enjoy
the rest of the flight take care